usa el método de completar el cuadrado
para encontrar las raíces de la ecuación
cuadrática y es igual a 4x cuadrada más
40 x más 280 y bueno lo primero que me
gustaría preguntarme es que es una raíz
y una raíz de una ecuación cuadrática es
aquel valor de x que hace que yo sea
igual a cero por lo tanto lo que tengo
que hacer es igualdad esta ecuación que
tengo aquí a cero para ver qué valores
de x o qué valor de x me dan esta
propiedad es decir son raíces y bueno lo
que voy a hacer entonces es igualar a
cero me queda que 0 es igual a 4x
cuadrada más 40 x más 280 y está después
de todo es divisible entre 40 440 y 280
es difícil entre 4 por lo tanto lo
primero que voy a hacer es dividir todo
entre 4 para que me sea mucho más fácil
completar el cuadrado perfecto entonces
este entre 4 este también entre 4 este
también entre 4 y esto también entre 40
entre 40 4 entre 4 se van se cancela y
solamente me queda ex cuadrada 40 entre
4 es muy fácil es 10 por lo tanto me
queda 10
y después lo que a 280 entre 4 28 entre
47 me queda 70 y ya tengo aquí una
ecuación cuadrática que es mucho más
fácil de trabajar para completar el
binomio cuadrado perfecto y precisamente
como yo lo que quiero es completar el
binomio cuadrado perfecto entonces voy a
dejar aquí un espacio para que yo pueda
poner aquí el cuadrado del segundo y
bueno como ya hemos analizado en varios
vídeos para sacar el segundo término lo
que hay que hacer es dividir el
coeficiente que está al lado de la equis
que es 10 entre 2 entonces dice 10 si lo
divido entre 2 me da 55 si lo elevó al
cuadrado es decir 5 es la mitad de 10 y
aquí tengo 2 veces el número de segundo
entonces 5 si lo elevó al cuadrado me da
25 y en el momento de que yo agrego 25
en ese mismo momento método criticar que
esto es un tener me cuadrado perfecto y
además que tengo que quitar 25 porque
recuerda que si yo agrego 25 de la nada
tengo que restar 25 también de la nada
no puedo dejar mente sino nada más
porque sí pero ahora lo que tenemos ya
está mucho mejor porque x cuadrada más
10 x más 25 los primeros tres términos
el lado derecho de esta ecuación x
cuadrada + 10 x + 25 es un trinomio al
cuadrado perfecto que se puede
actualizar en un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto en que binomio cuadrado
perfecto pues esto es lo mismo que x 5
elevado al cuadrado si te das cuenta que
tengo el cuadrado del primero más 2
veces de nuevo por el segundo más el
cuadrado del segundo x cuadrado más 10 x
más 25 y por lo tanto esto lo voy a
factorizar como x + 5 todo esto elevado
al cuadrado y después tengo menos 25 más
70 menos 25 más 70 también lo puede
reducir tengo 70 menos 25 es lo mismo
que 70 menos 20 que 50 menos 5 es 45
entonces me queda x más 5 elevado al
cuadrado ya esto le tengo que sumar 45
más 45 y bueno esto no hay que olvidar
que es igual a cero lo que queremos es
encontrar las raíces de esta ecuación
cuadrática y como lo que yo quiero es
despejar a x lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es quitar este 45 de aquí y
lo voy a pasar de otro lado con signo
negativo o dicho de otra manera de una
manera más formal lo que voy
y restar 45 de ambos lados de la
ecuación por lo tanto voy a poner menos
45 aquí y menos 45 del lado izquierdo
aquí es menos 45 y x menos 45 y voy a
hacer las correspondientes operaciones 0
menos 45 me quedan menos 45 después me
va a quedar menos 45 es igual a x más 5
elevado al cuadrado x más 5 elevado al
cuadrado y después tengo 45 menos 45 lo
cual se cancela
esto me da 0 por lo tanto del lado
derecho solamente me queda x más 5
elevado al cuadrado y bueno ya que tengo
esta igualdad lo que voy a hacer para
seguir con la idea de despejar a x esta
carrey es cuadrada de ambos lados de la
ecuación y bueno si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos un gran problema porque el
problema es que no hay raíces de números
negativos o no hay raíces de los números
negativos al menos en los reales cuando
yo me fijo en el plano cartesiano estoy
hablando de r2 es decir de los reales
cruz los reales y por lo tanto raíz de
45 no es un número real recuerda que no
existen ningún número que multiplicado
por si mismo te dé un número negativo en
los reales
este es un número imaginario y es que al
final date cuenta que no existe ninguna
equis tal que al sumarle 5 y elevarlo al
cuadrado mete un número negativo no
existe ninguna equis que cumpla esta
igualdad que satisfaga esta ecuación y
es que recuerda que la raíz cuadrada de
menos 45 no es un número real es un
número complejo y cuando nosotros nos
fijamos en un problema de este estilo
estamos pensando solamente en los
números reales por lo tanto déjame
escribirlo raíz de 45 no es un número
real no es un número real es un número
complejo y aunque seguramente me vas a
decir sal yo he visto los números
complejos en algún curso de matemáticas
cuando el yo busco raíces necesito que
estas raíces estén en los números reales
por lo tanto no existen raíces reales
que cumplan esta ecuación cuadrática y
bueno al final date cuenta que esta
expresión no es nada sencilla de
factorizar y no es nada sencilla de
factorizar porque no existen raíces
reales